des restrictions qui font grincer des
dents à l'exaspération monte face aux
mesures annoncées par les autorités de
plusieurs pays européens
si certains fatalistes juste
indispensable les privations de liberté
qu'implique la propagation exponentielle
du virus d'autres choisissent d'exprimer
leur colère
et cela donne lieu à des scènes
d'affrontement ces derniers jours entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre comme
ici à rome capitale italienne
au point que le président de l'italie
sergio matar est là à rappeler chacun à
la responsabilité pour lutter contre le
virus
à l'occasion d'une cérémonie d'hommage
aux victimes du coc vite 19
et comme l'a énoncé mortes et on doit se
souvenir de nos morts est un devoir qui
doit s'accompagner du devoir de
responsabilité s confiseurs pour suivre
l'engagement pour combattre et vaincre
cette grave maladie
en mettant de côté la partisanerie le
protagonisme l'égoïsme pour unir les
efforts de tous quels que soient leur
rôle ou leurs convictions quant à la caf
et sordo dans le but commun de défendre
la santé des personnes et d'assurer la
relance économique de notre pays
même chose à barcelone en espagne où le
centre ville a été le théâtre
d'échauffourées quelques centaines de
protestataires réunis pour exprimer leur
ras-le-bol des décisions émanant des
autorités
les mesures imposées par le gouvernement
espagnol
et plus précisément par la généralité de
catalogne n'ont aucune logique
elle ne repose sur rien et n'ont aucun
sens ce qu'elle doit faire
c'est imposer davantage de mesures aux
hôpitaux leur fournir du personnel du
matériel les aider à surmonter cette
pandémie et non les mesures de contrôle
social qui nous impose
ils ne peuvent pas nous retirer nos
droits fondamentaux ils ne peuvent pas
nous dire qui nous enferment chez nous
ils l'ont déjà fait une fois pendant
quinze jours et ça a duré quatre mois
je me force à ni logique ni légale parmi
les secteurs très touchés par ces
mesures de restriction la culture en
allemagne le personnel de l'opéra de
munich digère mal le fait qu'il doive
fermer pour quatre semaines
nous trouvions dans une situation très
sûr ici et quand je vois qu'aujourd'hui
tous les transports en commun que les
supermarchés ont le droit de rester
ouverts et que les théâtres et opéras où
l'on peut maîtriser les risques et où
les gens sont très disciplinés doit
fermer nous ne trouvons pas cela adéquat
dasri
outre la perte de liberté de mouvement
donc les conséquences économiques et
sociales sont très redoutés et la
patience des citoyens est plus que
jamais soumises à une rude épreuve